I've told you before that the term a
fake news much like regressive has
become used so commonly as this kind of
like catch-all ad hominem that it's lost
a lot of the meaning that it originally
had and we actually have a new study now
that confirms this there's a new Gallup
Knight Foundation survey and it found
that 42% of Republicans consider
accurate news stories that are negative
about a politician or about a political
group as always fake news now you might
say well David I'm sure Democrats are
just as bad right and you would be wrong
because only 17% of Democrats believe
that accurate accurate negative news
stories are fake news it's still
horrible but it's not nearly as bad as
the 42% of Republicans that said so this
actually confirms a victory for Donald
Trump in his use of the word because
fake news used to mean either satirical
news or deliberately misleading
propaganda news from those conspiracy
websites and from others but the
trumpian use of fake news at the
trumpian
use of fake news towards any critical or
negative reporting has now expanded the
meaning to the point that it actually
has no meaning at all what can we do
about this I actually don't know I'm
really at a loss because this isn't
going to be going away it's very easy to
look at these people who say any
negative story about Trump is fake news
and say those morons but it's here to
stay
there's a handful of Trumpets that email
me regularly any time we do a negative
story about Donald Trump which is pretty
often and they say with no hint of
sarcasm or of joking or of
self-awareness whatsoever they say David
that story is fake news and I don't know
if they can't tell the difference or if
they're refusing to see the difference
between actual news and just critical
reporting and it goes to something I've
been saying for a long time we're not
going to convince these people we're not
going to convince them that they've been
bamboozled by Trump it's just not going
to happen so if you want to get involved
in the 2018 election there
if you want to get involved in the 2020
election forget about going and arguing
with trumpets and trying to get them to
see the light and some at this point
nearly miraculous way just work on
getting out the vote only half the
country votes we can vote all of them
out on voter turnout alone just by
mobilizing people whose politics already
align with ours don't waste your time on
these people it's just not going to work
we've got a great program for you today
a very quick story upfront here at the
top of the show because we have so much
to get to thrilled you're with us on the
Friday program today today's episode of
the David Pakman show is made possible
in part by brilliant which is an amazing
website that lets you engage in fun and
interesting problems and puzzles in
order to learn more about really almost
anything related to math science and
engineering brilliant is a vibrant
community of over five million members
that brings together the expert
knowledge and experience of students
educators and professionals from all
over the world to create an incredibly
interactive learning environment and
learning in the presence of an actual
community really makes a difference when
you use brilliant you're in the company
of over five million members who share
your curiosity and love for math and
science and engineering and the
community at brilliant supports you're
learning you build an emotional
connection with the subjects of your
learning by interacting with other
learners and that's what sets brilliant
apart from other educational websites
you can get started right now by signing
up for free at brilliant org slash David
Pakman and the first 200 people who
visit brilliant org slash David Pakman
will get 20% off an annual premium
membership that is brilliant org slash
David Pakman